[Musique]
laurie perret bonjour j'ai ma venue pour
votre vip vais y paie vers yvelinoise
personnes
on va parler voilà je vous explique
l'acronyme on va parler de votre
spectacle et puis de vous aussi le
parisien dans son édition du 3 septembre
dernier vous décrivez comme alors je
vais citer grivoises et grisante sais je
cite toujours son allure de femme fatale
jupe moulante et rouge sur l'élève
contraste avec son langage très entre
parenthèses fleuri ça vous va comme
définition mais cela comptera se sait
que la tenir et je suis dire au monde
poser la question confie n'en voulait
pas à laisser les mains tout simple mais
c'est ça vous convient en tout cas de
jouer sur ce registre là d'avoir aussi
le décalage peut être sur scène trop ce
côté peut-être plus femme fatale et puis
avec un langage très fleuri on va
reprendre les mots du parisien nettement
fait c'est un personnage c'est pas c'est
pas moi bien que le langage fleuri mme
définissent comme un petit peu spectacle
alimentaire en attendant la pension
c'est le nom de votre spectacle à
découvrir jusqu'au 31 décembre au
théâtre république à paris on en voit
l'affiché puis ensuite ce sera pour les
saint quentinois à manier un mot le 18
janvier là aussi les dates seront bien
sûr s'afficher avec les les adresses
pour les réservations
ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore on va
regarder un petit extrait d'un de vos
sketches on regarde ça tout de suite et
ça fait c'est le nombre de ses doigts
[Musique]
c'est le nom de centimètres et ça me
fait pas plus moche d'une bonne vraie
[Musique]
impossible
il est happé au mcs a inscrit comme un
pas qu'on est triple madame il est trop
tard pour appeler l'anesthésiste canard
je perds réseaux locaux qui demandent
pourquoi il n'y a plus de réseau je veux
savoir ce que tu fais patrick tu
cherches une barquette scénique sur le
bon coin on a vu un trop mal mais les
mousses sont en plastique
voilà le ton est donné avec cet extrait
c'était lors du passage chez chez cauet
voilà la radio aussi bien évidemment
film et c'est ce moment qui vous a fait
le plus connaître alors oui c'est vrai
que c'est une très grosse surprise parce
que
pour moi c'était qu'un passage radio du
coup quand j'ai su que c'était en
facebook live j'ai eu le
mais bienveillant de mettre du rouge à
lèvres bah on m'avait dit mais comme un
facebook live mais du coup c'est vrai
que ça avait bien fonctionné et le
landau deux jours après je crois qu'ils
ont pris la liberté et de 8 en vue cette
formidable idée de lacoste et sur les
réseaux et de mettre les paroles et
ouais c'était les fous ce jour là mais
mon téléphone un peu brûlé de
notification vive et qu'est ce qui se
passe effectivement ça fait un gros buzz
et auquel on s'attendait pas eh ouais
c'est très cool alors ça c'était un peu
le point de départ on va dire dans début
de notoriété mais votre parcours est
assez long on va avoir le temps d'y
revenir juste pour rester sur ce
spectacle ce qui est formidable c'est
que vous dites à peu près tout ce qui
vous passe par la tête complètement
voilà on avec légèreté absolue et ça
passe tout seul on tombe jamais vraiment
dans la vulgarité en fait je si ça le
défi
ouais ce que je souhaite c'est que je
crois que j'ai réussi à ses personnages
auxquels on en compte on excuse tout
parce qu'on semble caler complètement
fragile et qu'effectivement la pas les
codes de ce qui se dit et de ce qui se
dit pas donc elle dit tout ce qui lui
passait exactement
et elle raconte des trucs dont on se
serait bien passé et effectivement voilà
on lui pardonne et ça me permets moi de
te raconter des trucs parcours de mère
célibataire avec son nom mais c'est
évidemment grandement inspiré parce que
je crois que je peux pas écrire des
trucs qui me qui me parlent pas ou qui
me correspond pas donc oui il ya des
situations avec mon enfant qui m'ont
amené ses conclusions la genre notamment
quand je parle de la maternelle et de et
de mes grandes problématiques matinale
de ne pas pouvoir me réveiller ça c'est
complètement vrai par ce qui explique
qu'on enregistre cette émission
l'après-midi par exemple a life est la
troisième fois que je desquelles ce
spectacle en tout cas vous êtes inspiré
un petit peu de votre vie personnelle et
puis de votre fille aussi vous en parler
pendant le spectacle
c'est là là c'est là la jama elle
s'appelle jeanne à chaque club elle a
quatre ans et demi elle va avoir cinq
ans là et quand elle était toute petite
avec nous disait qu'elle s'appelait la
la eric là
mais pas dire son prénom et du coup à la
maison c'était vraiment son surnom est
maintenant c'est son nom de scène
puisque fait vraiment partie intégrale
or lui montrer le spectacle non non mais
ce sera très bas grand falloir l'assumer
après du coup c'est vrai que j'ai très
souvent des problèmes de baby sitting et
j'ai norman souvent avec moi sur des
prestations et est arrivé à un moment où
évidemment je ne pouvais plus jouer
devant elles parce qu'elles finissent
par comprendre et donc j'ai les version
bis de mes chansons
même si notamment 1 2 3 qui fait 1 2 3
c'est le nombre de pizzas 2,3 que j'ai
mangé chez papa voilà il faut le savoir
pour ceux qui viennent voir le spectacle
quand il ya ces versions là c'est que la
petite n'est pas loin voilà c'est ça on
va dire que vous êtes sur scène je
chanterai toujours ma version
mais voilà en off on chante ça il n'y a
pas longtemps devenu que matt sur un
plateau et il y avait pour ceux qui
connaissent jarry et cartman qui était
en loge avec mon enfant et qui chante
être très très fort la version wii on
n'est pas vraiment connue on remonte un
petit peu avant ce spectacle vous avez
commencé l'improvisation à déclic
théâtre à la trappe comme tant d'autres
championne de france ça d'un pro en 2001
et s'est même issa doumbia qui vous a
poussé un peu sur scène qui vous a monté
sur cm et ça c'était mon pâte et très
rapidement quand on se rencontre j'ai 15
ans et
on est complètement débile l'un et
l'autre et on a un vrai coup de coeur et
il me dit mais bien faire de l'impro
parce que chez nous il ya pas de fille
et quand je suis venu j'ai compris
pourquoi n'y avait pas de filles
il fallait survivre parmi eux parmi ces
fous et voilà et c'est devenu une drogue
j'ai jamais pu m'arrêter d'enfer et
c'est surtout que les garçons que j'ai
rencontré à l'époque sont toujours mes
amis j'avais 15 ans j'en ai 34 et 20 ans
quand même qu'on avait fondé une famille
quoi vous les voyez encore hier soir il
était sur scène aussi quelquefois avec
eux il ya un spectacle prochainement
leur pro familia genre grise là et j'ai
mon ami mon frère mathieu longatte qui
vient de qui est plus connu sous le
pseudo de bonjour tristesse et qui
commence son spectacle qui est en rodage
c'est lui qui m'a présenté son
producteur donc on a le même producteur
on joue dans la même salle
voilà tous étaient fiers de ce mois ci
mais l'histoire une improvisation vous
sert donc encore aujourd'hui pour vos
spectacles
oui même dans la vie absolument
pour jouer un peu avec le public à cette
partie là aussi dans le spectacle à
découvrir actuellement vous jouer un
petit peu avec avec les spectateurs
complètement un peu à leur dépend
parfois web et ont toujours ce jour
j'essaie de diamètre de toujours
bienveillant de parts et les gens
et puis je ce que j'aime aussi c'est de
pouvoir me dire que bien que ce soit le
même spectacle de me dire que vous
pouvez venir le revoir dans un mois ou
deux ce sera pas forcément le même ça
j'aime bien ce sera l'occasion justement
de retourner voir ce spectacle
comment vous travaillez justement seuls
deux parfois avec alors j'ai qu'au début
c'est vrai que j'ai eu des années qui
m'ont aidé et j'ai mon ami jérôme bertin
qui m'a aidé à pimpé comme on dit mais
sketch g franck lebon qui m'a aidé sur
la plaine 10 en musique par exemple de
la première chanson
aujourd'hui je vole un peu plus de mes
propres ailes mais oui j'ai une équipe
j'ai mon producteur qui est très
important j'ai florent salomon qui est
comme une sorte de directeur artistique
de des sketches que je fais voilà c'est
dit mathieu mathieu longatte et mes
potes parfois avant j'ai écrit des
sketches c'est difficile quand on a tout
seul chez soi de se dire est ce que
c'est drôle
donc voilà j'ai une liste et je fais je
sais vous comment ça marche et à
l'origine vous auriez dû avoir un
musicien avec vous franck lebon voilà
deux ans je vous parlais tout à l'heure
et il aurait dû venir sur la première
scène pour le ouvert parce que l'homme
était seul avec le petit santé mais
normalement au concours de circonstances
ce spectacle moi je voulais être
chanteuse à la base vraiment et je
voyais tous mes potes de l'impro finir
en one to one man show et me dire oh
mais qu'est ce tu fous être tamisier qui
revient et non moi je veux pas faire des
blagues je veux faire de la musique
et puis j'ai créé j'ai fait mozart
l'opéra rock parce que j'étais vraiment
chanteuse est en revanche jamais aussi
vraiment rigolé donc j'ai écrit une
comédie musicale un peu débile pour mes
copines de mozart et ça représentait du
budget une prod et ça je ne savais pas
des marchés donc je me suis dit je vais
faire un truc à effectif réduit et si ça
fonctionne j'aurai plus de crédits pour
vendre ce projet de jeu prépare un duo
avec cette fameuse franck lebon et
qui est un compositeur de génie et qui
souvent orientés dans l'humour et j'ai
une copine qui me dit je suis juré d'un
concours d'humour fait le jean par la
france mais oui il faut le faire moi
j'étais pas du tout beauté je voulais
pas le faire c'est lui qui me dit ici il
faut que tu le passes donc j'écris ma
première chanson qui est prend la vie du
bon côté lui m'aide à faire les
arrangements et trois jours avant
évidemment ils devaient m'accompagner et
trois jours avant la prestation je peux
pas venir et me manque les accords et il
me dit c'est cool parce qu'en plus comme
tu joues mal c'est beaucoup plus drôle
est donc malheureusement j'avais demandé
à ma copine si elle pouvait me pistonner
parce que le deuxième prix c'était de
l'argent et elle n'a rien pu faire pour
moi puisque j'ai gagné le concours et
que le guen c'était de faire la première
partie de la mine les gad et donc
j'étais bien emmerdé parce qu'il fallait
que j'écrive un minutes supplémentaires
il a fallu improviser avec un petit
piano comme ça il fallait que j'écrive
20 minutes supplémentaires ensuite j'ai
fait une autre prestation m'a demandé 30
minutes
on m'a dit voilà site à 30 minutes en
monoski toi est ton enfant alors comme
j'ai entendu le mot gratuit j'ai
évidemment dit que j'avais trente
minutes
et donc ce spectacle est devenu une
sorte de concours de circonstances et de
et de commandes en fait on finissait par
me commander des minutes et je me suis
retrouvé à voir bout de quatre mois 45
minutes et j'ai fait des showcases et
mon ami mathieu mon meilleur ami m'a dit
si tu veux je te ramène mon producteur
et après c'est comme sélectionner l'un
des meilleurs producteurs de paris il
est le meilleur vecteur de farine
la chanson c'est définitivement oublié
maintenant nada spectacle ah oui la
chanson de ce style là on peut peut-être
écouter ça soit encore
mais vous faites c'est la raison d'être
des enfants de la télé on trouve de tout
sur latvala c'était plutôt r'n'b soul
voilà c'était plutôt r'n'b de la merde
je regrette pas effacé les skyblogs il
faut pas les laisser je parle avant que
minutes d'imagés à florent tu peux
effacer ça tout de suite
ouais ouais non je regrette pas parce
que j'ai l'impression que chaque chose
est un peu comme un effet papillon si
j'avais pas fait ça j'en serais pas là
aujourd'hui
donc mais évidemment je ferai pas de
promo sur seille puisque donc vous avez
décidé de rester dans ce registre là où
de revenir peut-être perdu 4 plus
classiques aussi vous avez parlé de
mozart l'opéra rock aussi il ya
plusieurs carrières qui s'offrent à vous
aujourd'hui où vous êtes vraiment sûr ce
spectacle un second spectacle dans la
même veine garder ce personnage
alors j'aime bien votre question parce
que c'est vrai que d'habitude en valeur
relative aux risques et ça que j'aime
pas trop dire que je suis humoriste je
crois plus que je suis une artiste comme
j'avais une proposition
et maurice tic est effectivement demain
je sais pas ce que j'avais envie de
faire mais j'ai des vraie passion pour
l'écriture pour la musique et pour le
comique
aujourd'hui c'est très cool de pouvoir
mixer ces trois choses sur un one est ce
que j'ai envie d'être seule toute la vie
je sais pas et peut-être que j'avais
envie de faire un deuxième spectacle
peut-être que j'ai envie de faire d'elle
une grosse comédie musicale une petite
comédie musicale tournée je suis pas des
vidéos sur internet aussi y en a
quelques unes en ce moment on voit on va
le mal
oui effectivement mais vous publiez
cette petite vidéo vidéo là c'est un
autre format c'est autre chose
voilà c'est une déclinaison de ce
personnage c'est ça c'est le même
personnage tel sur scène mais la queue
chez elle et qui donne des petits
conseils qu'il faut absolument pas
suivre et éloigné aussi les enfants vous
éloignez autre seuil avant d'enregistrer
les palaces on va regarder un autre
extrait justement bonjour tristesse
puisque vous en parliez tout à l'heure
pour ceux qui connaissent pas on regarde
un petit extrait bonjour tristesse vous
êtes bien dans le pays où manuel valls
nous a cassé les noms au marteau piqueur
pendant cinq ans avec l'identité
nationale
tout ça pour au final faire campagne à
barcelone dans le plus grand des cales
ils truquent d'élection il va même pas
au boulot celui-là c'est un scandale
pendant qu'ils cherchent en erasmus
politique par mois il nous coûte 24
mille bob et ça va s'arrêter à ces
quatre des trucs comme ça et on nous dit
pas être violent on aime on est
complètement impuissant
le jour où ça va faire de la
calligraphie à la bac sur sajoo le
français sera juste à court d'idées il
sera pas devenu méchant
voilà on l'avait reçue aussi d'ailleurs
ici et là des faits un reportage avec
lui tout à fait voilà je rappelle à nous
à permis quand même de passer de dîners
beaucoup plus tranquille ils appellent
ça voilà maintenant il fait ça dans ces
vidéos et nous laisse un peu tranquille
parce que sinon au quotidien c'était
mairie évidemment puisque évidemment au
naturel merci l'europe et rappelle que
ce spectacle alimentaire en attendant la
pension le nom de votre spectacle est à
découvrir jusqu'au 31 décembre au
théâtre république à paris et puis
ensuite ce sera à manier à les hameaux
le18
janvier on se quitte avec un dernier
extrait justement prend la vie du bon
côté on va le garder pour le plaisir
pour la vie du bon côté un autre extrait
de ce spectacle là tu te retrouves à la
basse et moi fleury mérogis
audi no 1 jour
notre site ma vie sans lui aussi
les problèmes tant qu'il est que ton
père m'en aller
en quatre ans la ville